Jesse why don't you hang out with anyone
it's like you don't want anyone to get
close to you a reclusive shut-in with a
powerful secret anyone I touch becomes
incredibly strong to the point of being
invincible no one should have that much
power an eccentric businessman hey Elsa
I think I've got to take off those
gloves today moving up in the world
anyone I touch becomes incredibly sick
usually to the point of death
a mysterious stranger who knows why I've
been following you for some time I know
what you are and a battle tell us what's
going on here there's no turning back
from it's all very simple the two of you
must destroy each other see the most
disturbing film of the year not because
of its commentary not because of its
psychological portrayal
but because it's not big on anything
what I said it's not based on anything
it has me based on comic it's not based
on a comic it's gotta be based on a
movie it's not based on a movie maybe
it's based on a show that wasn't bad it
wasn't great but still deserved more of
a chance it's not based on pushing up
daisies how can we take a gamble on
something without a fanbase you'll just
have to be interesting yeah
unpredictable
no not relying on nostalgia in human
love story
a black guy who was always written as a
black guy wait I wasn't originally
written as a white dude no and a woman
who was always written as a woman wait I
wasn't originally a white dude no how
are we supposed to cost controversy on
the Internet
you have to actually say something new
Oh relevant oh and rely on word of mouth
after it comes out
face the horrors of something original
it's like a bad dream huh oh thank god
goodnight
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to in 1965
a prime-time Western comedy aired on TV
called wild wild west and that's all you
need to know the movie has no connection
beyond that
based on the series about a duo of
cowboys who gained the gun-slinging
adventures the movie goes freeze it
different take with Will Smith as the
lead a steam-powered wheelchair with a
drunk kenneth branagh attached and a
giant mechanical spider blowing up
cities with fireballs
that's the big-screen adaptation I would
think of with a show like this
don't judge a house by its shudders how
about Windows not only is this known as
the worst film from Kevin Kline the
worst film from Kenneth Branagh and the
worst film from Barry Sonnenfeld for the
moment but this was the movie that
busted Will Smith's success streak after
leaving his mash show and making
gigantic hits all in a row this was the
first film to have us say dammit we have
to hate Will Smith in something granted
we would eventually get used to that
feeling but this was the movie that
started it did this show even have that
big following to throw this much money
at it did they think kids were really
gonna get excited for a Western from the
60s it's one of Hollywood's biggest head
scratchers so what the hell went wrong
well saddle up and get ready to cry into
the sunset
this is wild wild west and you
immediately lost me how'd you do that
how did it was that a second was that
even a second that was amazing what
would make me want to know what happens
to a man with a hubcap neck brace being
chased by a plastic pizza from the Ninja
Turtle toy this movie raises questions
like why would I want to watch this
movie he then cut but um pop - Will
Smith making love in a water silo trust
me this isn't the only time a large
group of people will taste Will Smith
not giving a shit mmm that's good algae
I'm not working oh don't worry will
nobody will think you're working when
you're in this film
problem solved I'm on there Belle you
can't just go ramming a man's personal
things into some hole like that Oh
we big chair actually it's film was
pg-13 before that meant PG so you might
want to change that
oh don't be boy that works but it'd just
be raining black people in New York as
he falls out of the silo and onto a
bunch of smugglers well well we got us a
shine he wants to figure out where these
smugglers came from so he traces them
back to a brothel where Kentucky Fried
Jesus um I'm just not interested okay
does this Western take place in
progressive times or is that honestly
supposed to fool us oh I'm so sorry that
won't be possible I have a pot to
lighten high identify is unfunny gotta
be interested you're a whore I work
alone hmm huh thought you were above the
obvious booby trap line huh well don't
worry there's plenty of other unfunny
lines to make up for it like when we see
how Donald Trump inspects his wives hey
he sacrificed a lot and one of the
henchmen chooses Klein oh oh hey now I
know how Michael Bay gets people to see
his movies you ever really step back and
look at Megan Fox now tell me who's in
that sack in the other room which
scientist is it is it dr. Escobar who do
you work for who paid you to kidnap
Escobar and tell me who's stopping me
from being humorous until Bob's Burgers
interrupts but a wagon of explosions is
sent hurtling towards them now what
it blows up the tavern and we'll just
assume they survive yeah it's kind of
like Batman at a death trap who really
cares how he escapes outside of
everybody hey everyone
um I was looking for the tone does
anybody know the tone I'm getting kind
of a bad Lerman no Brooks thing is that
what we're doing I mean I see Kevin
Kline and more obvious bad makeup so I
didn't know oh oh oh we're supposed to
fall for that well I mean who is that
person obviously not Kevin Kline yeah he
does a dual performance in this as both
the spy and President Grant for honestly
no reason except to give the impression
that he's great at disguises I am the
president I'm Artemus Gordon how did you
know president went to West Point
essays Harvard also you're terrible at
what you do
yeah the comedy behind these disguises
doesn't work if they're this obvious how
much funnier would it be if when he's
dressed up like a woman
they hired a real woman like his makeup
is that good or even if he's gonna look
like himself why not have the voice of a
real woman come out of his mouth there's
like a million ways that this could
actually be made funny but nope instead
they're just like hey did you see fierce
creatures neither did anyone else so we
get steal from that one day it's going
to get you killed he talks about all
these kidnap scientists and of course
once Smith inclined to work together
because haha not only intelligence to
tell me that no you'd rather rely on
stupidity look you two were the best
I've got
really find this madman whoever he is
and please do so with half the props
from Jackie Chan's around the world in
80 days
asshole Smith catches up with Cline's
awful green screen but Klein's awfully
pointless trampoline floor leads
declines awfully unfunny knee-slapper oh
nice of you to drop in
do you like that line I got it from
fuller house I was putting the final
touches on my latest invention comedy
the impermeable yeah I knew you would
make that so they put a light in a man's
head to see the last thing you saw
before he died and realized they had to
go to a costume party to figure out
who's the villain behind it I'd go as a
government agent who's gonna shoot and
kill general bloodbath McGrath an armed
Negro cowboy costume in a room full of
white southern former slave owners yeah
why did the president choose a black guy
to blend into the deep south but perk
lines ever-expanding fetish he wants MIT
to dress up as a woman great you're
wrong touch my breasts just one touch
one okay you happy Gordon I'm touching
your breasts I knew it babe wait squeeze
it gently not that hard let's measure
the awkwardness from the faces you're
making right now you might notice a lack
of laughter and an inability to find joy
you'll find that your face has entered
the dazed and abandoned mode this is
when you slip into a hypnotic state of
annoyance where you want to be angry yet
all the motion has been drained from you
to a point where you don't even care or
remember why now you've shifted all the
buckwheat around buckwheat that's your
problem
now touch my breasts upon further
inspection we now see that your face has
entered the hollow mode this is where
your mind has left your body leaving you
like the movie an empty hollow shell you
feel nothing want nothing so we'll take
nothing oh yeah that's what a breast is
supposed to feel like very nice the next
phase is called the dead mode you are
physically dead right now
you have surrendered your life to this
awful moment and it has claimed you you
discover that the afterlife is bleak and
meaningless attach yourself oh my god
I'm hard and finally we have the zombie
mode just when you thought death was the
end it turns out to only be the
beginning the pain suffering and
long-lasting thirst for blood will lead
you on a quest to search for brains but
find none from anyone who has been
associated with this movie I'm sorry I'm
just sorry
so Smith sneaks into the party where he
sees a dancer played by selma hayek
being forced against her will to make
love to a man and even gets choked to
partake in his kinky sex games Oh sucks
to be her off you go Will Smith
sometimes a bitch just gotta be choked
what a terribly clever costume mr. Jim
West yeah kind of wondering why it's not
getting here if nobody was gonna
question why I was here West meets East
merely east ma'am oh by the way there's
a woman getting strangled at a never
mind see anybody that looks familiar
matter of fact I do her name is joke
everyone can see coming where it's
actually a lady this time and not kevin
kline into your egg it's Norwegian I
think give our villain some credit for
having arguably the weirdest fucking
entrance ever seen in a western
I don't think Bugs Bunny could have come
out that smoothly don't you just hate
that song
I feel like Branagh missed his true
calling is a wacom song well y'all look
like you seen a go
this is dr. loveless because every
doctor with the word love and his name
has to be in a wheelchair and he seeks
revenge for the south losing the war
Smith however plans to stop him by
making obvious jokes I find that an
occasion to stand up I haven't seen him
in a Coon's a man of your stature to
keep in touch with even half the people
you know perhaps the lovely Miss East
will keep you from being a slave your
discipline they encourage you one minute
got the legs out from under you the next
yo mama's so fat she almost ate the
black off you mama's so fat you in a
wheelchair so Smith tells Klein to meet
him outside Klein being obviously here
and not here but the film things we
don't know that yeah for a big surprise
when you get this one in the saddle keep
holding my hand movie make sure I don't
poop myself in fact they think you're so
dumb that they actually end up doing
this joke twice maybe they think the
first time they did it was so subtle
that they just had to spell it out more
I'm him as the crowd wants to hang
Smith's for touching the woman's breasts
but figure is crueler to let him hang
himself for there is a solid two minutes
of Will Smith just talking on its own
and it's painful it's so painful it's
like watching a flame war the YouTube
comments not funny not smart and
everybody loses oh drumming on the
boobies thing all I was saying to the
gal was nice dress darling good to see
you my name's Jim how's your mama you
can actually see Will Smith's worth
dropping with every joke that bombs the
whole slavery thing I don't understand
what the big deal was anyway I mean come
on who wouldn't want folks running
around doing things for them doing Shore
then there was a redneck comment first
word red color passion fire power second
word
neck heel anybody gonna help poor man
but Klein saves him while also saving
Hayek as apparently nobody can catch up
to this incredibly slow moving carriage
of non speed slower slower my name is
Rita Escobar I came to find you yet
moist about the scientist my father
finally the and unnoticed yet hi ex
performance is not exactly the most
invested on the fried and starving
half-naked young woman who only wants to
find her father nice try buster what's
going on Oh aren't you boys Nuys youths
where she's focusing less on her acting
and more on eyeing the catering table
like the faster she finishes the faster
she can get to that delicious cronut but
what do you expect when you look over at
the director's chair and all you see is
this he's off to figure out how not to
work with Tommy Lee Jones Branagh
approaches his Confederate henchmen but
it looks like the movie wants to kill
itself as much as we do you sawed-off
sadistic bastard you surrender at
Appomattox
so who betrayed whom as one half of Gary
Oldman both literally and figuratively I
need my evil tie away my practicality
how's this for a joke he kills the guy
with the horn in his ear as the dog
takes a look recreating the RCA logo
that'll get all you young uns rolling in
the aisles every minute this movie
brings a new sight I didn't know I
couldn't make but hey after 50 minutes
of boob jokes deemed tanks and exploding
Abe Lincoln heads let's get serious for
a minute you saw it
I've heard about it week before the war
ended in 65 I was with the 9th cavalry
he discovered old folks women children
slaughtered they're using for target
practice
women and children used as target
practice wah wah West when I stroll into
the wild wild west oh man this movies
really saying something
obviously you really earned this super
dramatic Grimm moment let's allow the
emotion of this incredibly disturbing
imagery to sink in with jokes about some
of Hayek's a switch
mediately follows god the curvature of
her buttocks not even kidding the very
next scene is just making jokes about
her ass she's a breath of fresh ass you
said ass she's a breast of fresh air
let's just get some shut ass totally
makes you forget about the whole women
and children being used as target
practice
fuck I do wish more movies with mix
Pluto Nash style humor with Holocaust
imagery you know this film is so harsh
and empty I feel like Nietzsche wrote
something about it
well fucking said
you
so it looks like Bravo's train tries to
attack our heroes but hayek being quite
a whiny little crybaby uses the gas ball
to accidentally knock out Will Smith Jim
I did we miss a scene what a marvelous
train you know mommy borrowed is a
gentleman aside from a lack wheelchair
access I find a most comfortable way to
pass the long miles from here to my
laboratory yeah
try mother walking before the train
leaves I'm not sure how much of that
they're gonna pick up so like before a
buzz saw flies towards them to try and
take their heads off and here I thought
those collars were used to stop them
from chewing off any more scenery they
all run the saw but the Magnus seemed to
go haywire in their collars you all
right yeah I'm just peachy
can you help me get my boot off please
oh hey hey oh sorry all right Gordon I'm
gonna undo your belt I'm gonna run as
fast as I can that way you run as fast
as you can the other way
let me make sure I understand your plan
you're gonna run as fast as you can that
way and I'm gonna run as fast as I can
that way
so um was there anybody left in the
theater at this point on the store -
your grace was there any one person who
was like I want to see where this is
going I put my trust in this that this
will lead somewhere worthwhile the
insects who eat off the theater floor
are like and I read all the people go
yeah there's usually more food on the
ground in this is there a reason that
the projection is hello
with the Sun strip could it be that this
movie has something to do with it I
don't know let's watch Gordon I think
you need to calm down I can't be called
no no no no no no I'm the master of the
mechanical stop and I have to help you
you the master of this Cooper stop
that's yourself she's gonna gas me so
they escape and finally see what Branagh
has been working on this whole time
a great big mechanical spider I would
cut to my dr. Smith character doing the
traditional spiders thing but honestly I
don't think it's worth the makeup I know
it's not so Smith and Klein try to leap
into action do you know how to ride
don't you yes I know how to ride a horse
yes when the situation calls for
something primitive to about now there's
a gigantic spider stomping toward our
president and in that very moment right
after saying that line Bill Smith
realises I said yes to the script look
at his face you can totally see it in
his eyes you fucked up with the spider
makes its way to the president with
Branagh steering it good lord that is
the stupidest thing I've ever seen they
do the Will Smith what should have been
done to this movie as we're stuck with
several long minutes just hearing Brown
a prattle on the wrongs will be righted
the past made present the unit okay if I
want to watch Branagh overact and not
know what he's saying I'd watch Henry v
we make this as legal as possible him
personally I like the symmetry of it oh
yeah I forgot it's a silent film movie
so we have to have weird shots for the
sake of just having weird shots
I usually don't mind except that he's
way too in love with this one angle
seriously count how many times they cut
back to his pillow cheeked mug spinning
around like a drunk bumper car TT
sex was it open Manhattan for a handful
of beads and roll will be right
galux symmetry oh why would i will keep
coming back to the same shot of a person
just sitting down smith realizes the
movie left him so he tries to figure out
a way to sneak inside the spider and
it's just watch
yep a very select number of nightclubs
are made very happy right now well
everyone else watches in awkward
discomfort
what I love about this scene is that
brand has been addressing this gigantic
crowd of people this whole time and then
he just stops out of nowhere to get
horny and forces everybody to watch him
it's like if a football coach was giving
a speech and was like I want to know a
deep inside yourselves and find that
special go Bua cheerleader
um coach or you okay stop some of my
pants are jumping whoa uh can we at
least go yeah I'll watch my advances
Emily a veil I made a bunch of racist
comments earlier to a man who looks just
like you
but I'm suddenly gonna forget all that
and say hobo hobo oh you kid but the
breakout plan doesn't work well actually
it does they just go through the same
pattern of dumb lines and getting
captured again because of it's broke
don't fix it resulting in Smith fighting
off his henchmen well Branagh destroys a
random town huh don't know how we didn't
see that coming a literal mile away
I really should pay attention to more
current events that's it no more mr.
nice guy
so which game of Thrones death would you
like to give this movie red weddings
always good the poison goblet always a
classic
have you ever stuffed a horse inside
somebody but it's okay because just as
Smith looks like he's about to get axed
off um your guess is as good as mine I
have no idea what that was I guess if
you explain anything anymore
the terrorists win but Branagh turns
into a spider himself because that one
idiot who watched this all the way
through has to be punished somehow but
the Machine gets out of control and
walks its way off a cliff Branagh is
killed Smith and Klein are awarded by
the President and we're all reminded
that Salma Hayek was in this movie oh
yeah I'm afraid I haven't been
completely honest with you professor
Escobar is not my father he's my husband
well so not only does she contribute
nothing like at all but she was already
taking this whole time this
quote/unquote twist is so lame that even
the main characters point out how it
makes no sense you could've told us that
from the beginning Rita yes look at the
expression on Kline he legitimately has
no idea why this was a thing her
character the romance why she lied about
her husband being her father not one
goddamn answer yes I think they cut
before he grabbed the camera and stabbed
anybody who dared look him in the eye
and what high joke do they go out on to
end the film mind if I ask you a
question
actually I do Artie
um I'll share it with you when they
actually give one comedy that is what
this was meant to be right
this is one of the biggest high budget
cinematic question marks at least with
most bad unfunny films you have an idea
what they were going for and it just
didn't work this is like an anti comedy
just sees that happen and they're not
really sure if they're funnier
adventurous or dramatic just as long as
you're somehow suffering the chemistry
between the characters is non-existent
the effects are not very good the jokes
are uncomfortable at best and the amount
of dead air in between them could fill
the spaces between stars and on top of
all of that it's based on an idea that
I'm sure is fine for its time and has a
small audience but very clearly had no
success guaranteed in any part of it
even with all the money and celebrities
to put this comedy simply I just don't
get it but at the very least we know it
can't do anyone else any more harm I'm
the Nostalgia Critic could you like use
that can of raid on me oh sure god bless
you sir I remember it so you don't have
to coming next week it's a review of all
the Looney Tunes movies every single one
that's ever hit the theaters but you can
see it now under vessel's ad free early
access just three dollars a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early scoop
you
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing the
Starlight Children's Foundation since
being formed as an Australian children's
charity in 1988 this foundation has
brightened the lives of seriously ill
and hospitalized children young people
and their families throughout Australia
living with illness or injury can cause
enormous strain in the lives of children
and their families the pain loneliness
and isolation that sick children feel
dominates their lives and they often
miss out on normal experiences that
healthy children take for granted
starlight provides programs integral to
the total care of seriously ill children
while health professionals focus on
treating the illness starlight is there
to lift the spirits of the child giving
them the opportunity to laugh play and
just be children again if you go to
their website or especially their
YouTube channel you can see all the
adorable beautiful children that
deserves so much love and so much
laughter these are good people trying to
bring so much joy into the world and you
can help them do it definitely click on
the link and see what you can do to help
these wonderful people out take a look
and see how much love there is to share